I missed the pre-embargo screening
because I was out of town thank you for
your patience but now I've seen
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and now we
have work to do let's do it
[Music]
so Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is the
third Guardians of the Galaxy film James
Gunn's back to bring us this before he
exits and becomes solely the DC guy for
this third Adventure the Guardians are
back because one of their own he's in
trouble so if they go do a thing to save
his life which leads him to another
thing which really we're kind of on a
Space Rabbit Hole here and we have a few
characters to talk about here first of
all Gamora I want to talk about Gamora
because Gamora isn't really Gamora as
we've known her this is a new Gamora
from the Past who came to you know end
game right now I was pleased with what
they did with Gamora in here because you
know how shows movies stories have the
will they won't they Dynamic and then
they do and now that Intrigue is lost
and they know it so I thought their plan
was all right kill off Gamora bringing a
new Gamora from the pass and now we're
back to will they won't they and that
would have felt like they were taking
steps back and they did not do that I
like that I mean quill is trying to deal
with it but this Gamora is she's a
different Kimura she's actually she's
kind of a dick and that was cool she
fell felt like a daughter of Thanos you
know she was more hardcore our beloved
Gamora before she was you know she was a
fighter she was nice probably why she
went Splat and Rocket hands down the
best part of the movie are you kidding
me it's been said rocket is the heart of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. I don't
feel that's actually accurately
representing the situation it's more
like rockets movie is a better movie
wrapped in this Guardians 3 movie which
is by and large fine I think it's
heartfelt it's painful it's sad I like
that in here I'll get to why in a second
other than me being grumpy old man
energy you know that about me by now but
hold on in a second also the high
evolutionary as the villain of the film
I liked him also I liked him until he
starts just screaming at everybody and
then I was like okay you went from being
cool to being another villain who just
screams at everybody take your place
among the villains long forgotten who
just scream I get that's probably the
point of someone with a God complex yeah
I'd probably get pissy and scream but I
liked him when he was more collected and
just kind of belittlingly dickish but
largely the reason he works is because
of rocket and the dynamic between the
two I thought was fantastic and elements
or character in this movie I felt was
largely wasted was Adam Warlock maybe it
was the six year wait I don't know maybe
it was the fact we should have seen him
before infinity War so we could have
been in Infinity War
you know it's possible I mean when I
heard Will Poulter was Adam Warlock I
was excited I was like he's a great
actor let's see what he does but he
could have been played by anybody and
it's not even will poulter's fault the
script just didn't give him enough to do
I feel like this movie was like all
right Guardians movie
um you teased Adam Warlock in the in the
post-credits scene of Guardians too we
still haven't seen him we should
probably have him in here
fine let's make him a bounty hunter what
do you say like yeah yeah he'll try to
get the package the package being a
someone fine and that's largely what he
does he pounces onto the scene because
he's here to get somebody he's here to
kidnap someone and that's that that's
that's his quest I wish I kind of would
have been fine with if he had that
higher way of speaking so at least when
he's in a room talking people can be
like whoa it's like you're the guys like
you were created to be more oh you just
did an Alan Watts monologue that's at
least okay but that wasn't the case he
kind of felt like if Superman and his
powers went Splat with Pinocchio where
it's like oh you're kind of a really
powerful naive idiot who's not quite a
real boy he never even says anything
like I am less than human and far more
than mad like nothing like that however
Guardians 3 is a packed film so I kind
of get it where it's like oh we also
have to include Adam Warlock in a movie
with rockets backstory you have the
Guardians all working together and then
the band splits up because there are a
lot of them then you have the sub
Guardians you know the ones hanging out
on nowhere you have a lot of irons in
this fire and you have to include Adam
Warlock that's tough probably why you
should have done an atom warlock
Standalone film Maybe
just maybe and I heard they were going
to do a rocket Groot Standalone film and
include Rocket's backstory with that
that would have worked then you could
have had Adam Warlock come into this
movie and concentrate on his story and
the high evolutionary you have the high
evolutionary and then you have Adam
Warlock who's like the Pinnacle of
humanity and it's like they kind of
address that and they're like yeah no
we're going separate ways addressing it
isn't hammering at home there's two
different things they could have
hammered at home they did not just keep
Adam Warlock being the Bounty Hunter
type he has a couple funny moments
because MCU which largely does work for
Guardians and as the Guardians of the
Galaxy Adventure I thought the adventure
was fine you get exactly what you pay
ticket price for for Guardians of the
Galaxy a space adventure with a crew of
Misfits who largely yell at each other
more in this movie than they feel they
have before that did kind of get
annoying for me multiple locations big
CGI and then at a point they're like oh
for higher morality we have to help the
helpless people because we're the
Guardians right problem is I feel like
I've seen this before and not in that
I've seen this two other times because
this is Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
kind of way but more on that this is
another space adventure comedy in the
MCU I feel like I've seen that a lot
more and that's a bummer I do want to
judge this movie based on it being
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and it
does its part to be that whatever else
is going on in the MCU not its problem
we're the Guardians that's our thing the
problem is in the MCU the Guardians used
to be more unique they used to be the
misfit band that was going on the
comedic space adventure now comedic
space adventure that that's just MCU not
counting this movie two out of the
previous three MCU films were comedic
space adventure granted Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumanian not outer space
adventure more like Inner Space
Adventure Point is a group of people end
up on another world for an adventure
comedy so I'm gonna go ahead and count
it same energy as they say point is in a
world where these space adventure
comedies largely feel like what the MCU
box is and we have the Marvels coming
out so we got more coming this year I
rather preferred it when the Guardians
were the Misfits who were the space
adventure comedy and the MCU was largely
not bad the movie has its final Act CGI
blast that I mean every MCU movie has
that we know that's going to be the case
that would it would almost be weird if
Guardians of the Galaxy is a big space
adventure was like all right and no big
CGI third act it just kind of it's done
now the emotional things are what ended
it that said it does have some cool
visuals including this one corridor our
fight that's you know how it is one of
those One-Shot green screen fights among
a bunch of people where the Guardians
are fighting a bunch of monsters that
look like they're from the Doom video
game it's pretty great I love that scene
that was badass did it need to be in
there absolutely not is the movie too
long absolutely but of the things that
you could cut out of here that is one
I'd like to stay what is it about comic
book movies is this they're like all
right two and a half hours minimum not
that a long run time is innately bad but
I couldn't help but walk out of this
movie and be like yeah you could have
trimmed some Corners you could have cut
that one down in the end Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 it's a fine space
adventure it's a nice end to the
Guardians movies that I've heard it's
the last Guardians movie but ironically
and even sadly Guardians 3 feels more
like a familiar MCU formula film rather
than the unique Vision that started
Guardians of the Galaxy in the first
place get some beers get some friends
probably be a good time if you're drunk
yeah now it's a party but what I liked
most about it wasn't the fun Guardians
of the guy Galaxy Adventure it was
actually the Rocket Raccoon tragedy real
question is this the first MCU film to
drop the F-bomb because there is an
F-bomb in here I can't think of any
other one in any other MCU movie if so
well history has been made in a way all
right so Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
[Music]